we've previously discussed the father of
all monsters in Greek mythology - so
it's about time we now discuss the
mother of all monsters echidna the name
of kidnoh originated from the Greek word
hidden er mean and Viper and a kid that
was exactly that she had the upper body
of a woman at her lower half was a tail
of a coiling serpent despite being the
mate of typhoon a union that gave birth
to many of the most iconic monsters and
creatures in Greek mythology it is often
said that echidna lived alone in a cave
though it's likely she didn't get too
lonely as she was said to bring
passers-by back to this cave only to
devour them if the exact origin of
echidna isn't very clear the earliest
mention of hers in Hesiod's Theogony
were Hesiod describes her as being born
to a she many have come to the
conclusion that this she was The Seagull
Osito which would make her father forces
mean she had the same parents as Medusa
some however believe that this she was
actually the oceanic calliroi another
one of the children of four-season Seto
he was said that calliroi had three
husbands
Poseidon Nilus and kreisau the son of
Medusa and it is kreisau who is
considered the most likely to be the
father of echidna out of the three in
the years that followed Hesiod's
Theogony tales of echidnas parents range
from four-season an unnamed woman to
Styx and an unnamed man even to Gaia and
Tartarus and considering this is where
typhoon came from I think it's a
reasonable claim but what I'm really
trying to say is that there is no
definitive answers to where a kid nerv
really came from there are many
creatures in Greek mythology that are
attributed as the offspring of variant
deities and other monsters but the
following creatures have in some shape
or form been mentioned as a child of
echidna authoress the two-headed hound
Cerberus the three-headed guardian of
the underworld the lernaean hydra the
Chimera the sphinx the eagle that
torments Prometheus blade on the cremini
and Sal a female mythical bore the
colchean dragon and lastly Scylla now
you may have heard of many of these
creatures perhaps even with a different
mother and that's mostly because Greek
and Roman poets didn't always agree much
of their work is quite ambiguous and
left down to personal interpretation
echidna is often described as being
ageless and immortal and many believe
that she just faded from existence
however there is a tale where Hera sent
the hundred-eyed Giants are
pannabai tests to slay echidna in some
stories echidna was considered the
mother of serpents and Dragons she was
often associated with the dragon Python
who Apollo managed to slay as a child
now many of you may be thinking this
dragon was male so how exactly could
this be a Kidner well before the tale of
Python existed
Apollo killed an unnamed dragon that was
later named Delphine who was said to
have raised - when he was born
Delphine and echidna were very similar
in terms of appearance both being half
serpent and half woman there is also a
connection between echidna and the
Gorgons but that is something I'll be
saving for a future video so look out
for that if Gorgons are a topic that
interests you considering the role of
Kidner had in greek mythology
she's scarcely mentioned and mostly
shrouded in mystery so feel free to
share an intelligent an echidna with me
in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained